I loved this man's article about what a
major league baseball player will go
through on a game day should there be a
2020 playing season should baseball and
the Players Association get through
whatever negotiations are going right
now going down right now over money and
Jeff Passan of ESPN joins us right now
in his latest article again on espn.com
is a must read it is phenomenal and
that's one of the many reasons why I'm
having him back here on the show and why
he's kind enough to say yes how are you
Jeff I am well how are you I am great
thank goodness I'm knocking on wood and
you know what I haven't heard anything
lately we haven't seen anybody on Twitch
from the players side and I know the
Commissioner spoke to CNN last week I
think it was last Thursday we haven't
heard anything and I'm appreciative of
that because that's the one thing I've
had missed about sports is public
posturing over a monetary negotiation
and I'm wondering if that's on purpose
that we haven't heard anything in the
last few days I
III would like to think that all parties
would have learned their lessons in the
past and and yet as a media member I
also feel like I would be biting the
hand that feeds me to encourage all
people to be quiet about things in the
end though the long play it is better
for baseball when people do not speak
out publicly about sensitive issues and
that's why at the beginning of last week
rich I wrote this week it's gonna be
ugly
because they don't have discipline and
in the lack of discipline comes from the
elder side when things are being leaked
to particular writers and it comes from
the players side when they're going out
in public and answering questions that
probably don't help the general cause so
I think they've got all that out of the
way and it is brass tacks I'm and let's
figure out if they can actually get a
deal done to get baseball I don't feel
this year
all right so walk me through what you do
know about this even though some people
are not talking publicly anymore what is
your your ear
to the ground telling you about this cuz
as you point out rubbered must meet road
if you want to talk about getting people
in spring training i was part of your
great article is that some people have
said are we really supposed to be in
spring training in just three weeks time
june tenth right so what are things yeah
and a big part of that rich is because a
lot of these protocols that are in place
in this draft document really accelerate
the timeline even closer than that for
example people need to take an intake
screening is what it's called before
they get to spring training meaning
whether your spring training is going to
be in your home city or it's going to be
in your arizona florida complex
everybody needs to show up between 48
and 72 hours before their actual report
date now the report dates are going to
be a little bit staggered pictures
supposed to get there and then position
players and then sort of not quite as
essential personnel but the the fact
that this could start somewhere around
june 10th
means that guys are going to be getting
to these places june 6 7 8 that means
guys have to get back from the dominican
republic or from venezuela from colombia
over from south korea or from all these
different places around the world and
indeed logistical disaster that
discloses i think makes it unlikely that
those dates that they targeted are going
to be realistically achievable but look
then again you have people who are
extremely motivated to get something
done they will find a way to get it done
and and that in the end is how i see
this thing going is many complications
as there are difficult is it maybe I
still believe right now maybe not with
as much confidence as I had last week
for reading this document but I still
believe that baseball will be back this
year well because the point is and again
we'll we'll get to the document that
they sent out about health and
and public safety in a moment but we
can't go down this road right and
basically say it's too hard monetarily I
mean we can't go that answer right we
most certainly camera Johnson I think is
the devastating I think it would be
indicative of some sort of rock inside
of the sport that maybe the people don't
recognize but that is obviously there if
they can't not just at any moment come
to terms on a financial agreement but in
the middle of a pandemic when tens of
billions of people have lost their jobs
when they're live at food banks and when
when there are people who can't make
mortgage payments if you're gonna lose
baseball season because you can't figure
out how to split up a few billion
dollars you deserve everything that is
coming your way
I think the everything in Major League
Baseball's case here would be the
rebellion of a fan base that for years
that looked past 1994 it said we forgive
you for your mistakes so long as we
learn from them and this would be less
than that show it didn't really let it
go well there's got to be enough smart
people in the room the commissioners a
smart man Tony Clark there must be
enough smart people I do when I talk
with people on both sides
I say to them who's going to be the
adults in the room like who's going to
be the person who says you know it's
it's like Ted Turner in me you know back
in the 70s and I think the seventies
might have been early 80s but
uttered a very famous line I think it
was printed for the first time in John
Hale years seminal book on labor
relations lawyers around Ted Turner said
to his group of fellow owners gentlemen
we have the only lead
monopolies in America and were passing
it up and and I would and I would look
at all of the owners right now I would
look at all of the players and say
gentlemen you have the ability to have a
legal monopoly on the entire sporting
landscape in America do not evident well
and then in that regard to what what if
and I would certainly sit there and
think this if I'm on either side in that
respect and hopefully that we don't talk
about sides but we will talk about a
sport coming together and then figuring
out the remarkably difficult challenge
of playing in a pandemic and we'll get
to that again in a second with you Jeff
pass an ESPN senior MLB insider that
what if they decide to throw their hands
up and then basketball comes back and
then football comes back and then all of
a sudden they're the only ones that
couldn't figure it out because of money
and everybody else does I mean I would
sit there and think that that would just
absolutely crush that would just that
would be certainly since the
Commissioner says four billion goes out
the window if they don't play at all
right right so yeah and listen these are
all great points they're all very
obvious to me and to you I think it's
harder food for people who are
billionaires not that I feel sorry for
them by any means that they're losing
money right now cuz they're billionaires
i I think it's harder for them to to
stomach this and I I just I don't know I
look I look at baseball rich if it loses
a season to money and and just have a
really difficult time seeing a path
forward to prosperity and I think that
owners have to have to as the people who
tend to be in the game for even longer
than the players owners have to
recognize this and have to recognize
that
no season this year is a bad thing no
season this year because of money is is
just a self-inflicted wound
okay so let's all wave a wand Jeff
Passan and say they they come together
they figure this out that they're smart
people
okay then hallelujah III don't want to
give away all the goods in your article
and clearly that's you know impossible
since it was so in-depth and we have
about ten minutes time remaining here if
we can get through everything but here's
a deal I'd love for you to lay out what
a major leaguer would go through waking
up on a game day in a twenty20 Major
League Baseball season during these
unique times it would I was gonna say
unique is is certainly the right way to
explain it and you know as I was going
through the protocol for the first time
I there was just so much information I'm
like how the hell am I going to lay this
out there in a fashion that is not
completely boring and it occurred to me
let's look at what the day of a player
is going to be like and and see how many
of these different rules affect him and
it's like every single thing I came
across I was putting it in that section
of my outline I was like okay gonna
start and you wake up and you take your
temperature and then you take your
temperature again by the way under this
protocol every single person in Major
League Baseball will be getting their
own temperature if you don't have a
fever over a hundred degrees okay you
get to go to the stadium but if you're
on the road no taking an uber not
allowed to take ubers I get to the
stadium you have your own special entry
I
you better be wearing a mask because the
only place that you can't wear a mask is
on the field or if you're lifting
weights or doing something
strenuous you know you walk in the same
temperature take it again you go into
the clubhouse but it's not really a
clubhouse because there are many guys in
there and you got a socially distant 60
go out to the field most of the batting
practice is out on the field because
they don't want you using indoor cages
very much again practice social
distancing there's no hot tubs there's
no cold tubs that you know when you're
out on the field for a game time for
example no lineup card exchanged if
you're not playing in the game you're
going to be sitting in the stands for
seats between you and a fellow player
two rows between you and anybody else
during the game they they have asked for
you not to be close to guys unless the
ball is close to them as well so
socially distance during the game after
game you know we prefer if you didn't
take a shower that's actually the one
rich that angers the players the most
the lack of showers after the game will
not stand and it goes beyond that you
know there's not going to be any buffets
it's going to be all prepackaged meals
get back to the hotel if you're on the
road you're not going to be able to
leave it's just a lot for players to
handle it's nothing totally beyond the
pale it's nothing that they can't handle
it's just a ton for guys who are so used
to being the same to have to change what
about testing testings gonna be fine I
mean you know you're gonna be you're
gonna be tested a few times a week
they're gonna have a lab out in Utah
that does test Ana if you saw the story
in The Washington Post today rich but
testing you know fast
listen it's taken months but we are now
at a point where an abundance of tests
exist and some states are actually
actually have more tests than they need
so Major League Baseball played the
testing thing right you know there's
been like the whole thing at the
beginning with the NBA when when
frontline workers couldn't get test but
NBA teams could that that's not the case
anymore
and so I think the testing part frankly
is what's going to allow this to happen
the fact that Major League Baseball has
the seat of process more than 10,000
tests a week which is a lot of testing
that's being done so how often
players get tested Jeff I mean and and
wow we're at the clubhouse door anymore
yeah it's going to be at the stadium
it's going to be a saliva test that gets
taken and sent to a lab in Utah and you
will have the results within 24 hours if
there are players who are showing signs
and/or symptoms whether it is fever
cough or otherwise they have what's
called point-of-contact tests which are
essentially rapid tests that return
results within 15 minutes and while that
person is test results his or her test
results are waiting the person will say
in a specifically designed containment
area that every stadium will have for
cases like that
I'm telling you rich like the plans
thorough it has some gaps in it no
questions but the amount of time and
care that was put into it it's actually
really impressive and the the most
interesting part to me rich isn't just
that this is baseball this is the sort
of thing that America is going to be
going through in the next few months as
we reopen and other workplaces are going
to have the same thing so as as crazy as
it seems as daunting as it is to follow
some of these rules this is more I think
the reality going forward than otherwise
hey Jeff I was saying before you know
sports is really what I think
crystallized for the country large
sports is exactly what crystallized the
country at large about having to shelter
in place I mean when the NBA shut down
March Madness was sent you know what was
ended and so this this could be a way to
lead to show how businesses can reopen
and how we as a country need to realize
that again even though it feels
permanent this is still something that
is just temporary and the faster that we
could figure out how to live in the
temporary the quicker we can get to this
being permanently handled I get that
what happens if a player pops positive
though
what is the plan for that because we
know about asymptomatic and you want to
talk about the plan having some holes
come on what I'm hearing is from people
certainly on both sides wondering if
there are some 22 23 year olds who feel
like that they are you know asymptomatic
and thus superhuman that might go out
and and visit a bar go out and and bring
hundreds of more vectors into somebody's
Clubhouse or you know row or seat or
something like that Jeff rich rich
that's not just possible that's going to
happen right like there's just there's
an inevitability to someone testing
positive here there's just too many
people and and too much money and too
much ego and too much hubris to to
contain people for as long as you would
need to in order to create that bubble
and so I think that I think there's
going to be a positive test the way that
mLT's protocol is right now is that
person gets quarantined and is going to
be tested every day and when he or she
has two consecutive negative tests is
showing no symptoms and has the go-ahead
from a team physician or another doctor
that first think in return and that
could be as early as seven days now the
typical standard quarantine period were
used to is 14 days but MLB says that its
experts tell them that seven days with
those other things there's enough and I
would love to walk around asking people
to call me doctor passing because I
earned my medical degree but I did not
so I have absolutely no idea whether
that's right or wrong and have a tough
time sitting here question Amen what I
will what I will say is that I think all
of us rich I have to get used to the
idea of there being some very
uncomfortable things in all of our
futures even the experts even the ones
who do have
MD after their names don't exactly know
the way that this is going to play out
they have better idea than us but they
don't really know so there are going to
be mistakes that are made they're gonna
be screw-ups they're gonna be points if
baseball comes back at which people
think to themselves should they really
have done this
the answer may well be no but the answer
may also well be yes and that's what I'm
hoping that we can do allow this thing
as much as possible as long as large
swathes of people are not getting ill
because of it to play itself out because
that's all we're all trying to do on
today and and you're right I think the
testing aspect is is crucial to show
that we can do it and you know one thing
that definitely struck me in your
article is that the 26 major league
city's baseball is going to include in
their free testing people who are on the
front lines who may be looking for a
test
trying to get tests like they're going
to share their tests with people on the
front lines battling copa90 every health
care worker in pretty much in every
major metropolitan area in the United
States can get a cup of tests for free
through MLD that's essentially what the
league is saying that that really struck
me as well as you know they're gonna
remove baseball's that I guess they're
at any point put in play right I mean
because that might mean somebody would
touch it delivering it to the plate and
then someone would touch it delivering
it either back into the infield because
it was hit safely or to first base and
then that would be I mean it really is
overwhelming but it's possible none of
it none of it is that they're saying
this is impossible
none of it I read was saying that this
is beyond the realm of possibility in
individually nothing is impossible
collectively it's hard it's really hard
and in some of it rich
some of it's overkill but it's overkill
it's purposeful overkill it's overkill
with the idea that they're going to need
to be health commissioner's
in every city they try and go to we're
gonna have to say yes we will allow you
to play and if you're coming at them
with a detailed 67 page more when it's
done document write about all the things
you're going to do to ensure that Koba
does not spread around it's pretty great
place to start just from a moral
authority standpoint you know we want to
do this
and we are going to put our time effort
money behind sketching out as good of a
proposal as you will see yeah and again
you know that I hope just I guess to
bring this full circle here isn't
another one of the hang-ups that's gonna
go down in the negotiations between
players and Major League Baseball's just
like no spitting huh I mean am I gonna
get fined $300 every single time you
know if ESPN catches me spinning on the
ground because you know I forget where I
am because or things have actually been
created in a bubble community so well
that the players forget where they are
and they just they just feel normal like
III hope that everyone understands like
we are putting this on a piece of paper
for a reason and if we can follow this
all the way to the letter
we will keep you safe but let's all just
do this put it on a piece of paper and
then figure it out as best we can to go
along so we can all sit there and see
this thing but then again I'm not the
one who's suiting up you know what I
mean
and that that is I guess the essential
aspect of this and that's you know what
that's that's the thing that we have to
keep in mind here as much as we want to
say and as much as people's instincts
can be this is too much don't even
bother if the players say we want to
play we want to do this we're willing to
write some I try to play like alright
just seems like if if the players are on
board and if the teams are on board good
place to start and and if they're going
to do this as as responsibly as an
entity of their size can and I I have a
difficult time understanding the
argument saying just shut it down
next year why because it's complicated
why because it's hard it's America man
we love doing complicated things and
hard things and we fail at it a lot but
we go down swinging and that's what
baseball if nothing else needs to do
this year that's I mean that's the JFK
again I'll keep saying I said it
yesterday that we go to the moon we
choose to go to the moon not because
it's easy but because it is hard and
this is this is a lot of moon shots
right here from creating a vaccine to
obviously trying to return sports and I
think everyone's gonna give it a try I I
know the NFL's nuts it here thicken in
May we're not gonna give this a try and
let's figure this thing out is they're
gonna keep everybody else I'll tell you
what though rich and I knowing that you
spent a lot of time thinking about the
NFL talking about the NFL yeah at the
end at the end of reading through this
thing one of the first thought in my
head was I have no idea how football is
going to come back if these are the
sorts of restrictions on a sport that is
already naturally socially business I
hear you Jeff no doubt about that you're
spot on and saying that and that's one
of the many reasons why I love having
you on here it's a great conversation as
always and keep looking for my texts and
phone calls I really enjoy your work
it's it's it's comprehensive and it's
well-written and it's well thought and
you're my first choice so thanks for
coming on Jeff you know I really enjoy
what's that I enjoy your hair in the
last room as well I looked at it like if
that's what your 12 year old thinks what
do you think my 11 year old thought my
own son my own flesh and blood
let them unleash their hell on the world
wonders anything like mine we're all in
trouble
yep absolutely thanks for the call Jeff
appreciate it okay it's Jeff Passan hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here